time now for pft on yahoo sports chris
sims in for peter king mike florio here
with you as always to discuss some of
the big stories in the nfl no bigger
story now than what in the hell is wrong
with the pittsburgh steelers chris they
have lost three in a row after winning
11 in a row coach mike tomlin almost
seemed resigned to the fact that his
team's not very good right now he said
so but he believes they can fix it do
you believe with games looming this
weekend against the colts and if they
lose a potential winner take all
showdown against the browns for the afc
north championship in week 17 do you
believe the steelers can fix their
current problems like they can fix it i
don't know if it's gonna directly
correlate to winning the next two
football games though you know it might
not you know right now they're gonna
just worry about fixing it so then when
they get to the playoffs they can feel
like we're somewhat close to where we
want to be and we can win football games
hey we know bud dupree devin bush being
out that's hurt their defense they're
not quite as dominant as we've seen them
be you know they're not making as many
uh you know eye-popping turnovers strip
sacks things like that i think yes
because some of those guys are missing
but also teams have realized wait let's
not take any chances against the
pittsburgh defense the pittsburgh
offense is not all that great right now
so we'll play really conservative not
let the defense the pittsburgh defense
beat us that's been hurting them and of
course the offense there's got to be
some change there you know we saw the
run game get going a little bit but big
ben's play has certainly not been up to
par the receivers i think we have to put
them in the boat there too hasn't been
up to par by them either i mean chase
claypole to me is the only guy that you
can consistently count on there so uh
there's work in progress has to be done
but the formula on offense is the
biggest concern and that's got to change
to a degree because i have more faith in
the defense than the offense at this
point
you mentioned claypool yeah we've seen
what he can do this year
they don't showcase him enough i agree
maybe designing plays to get the ball in
his hands other than a jet sweep that
goes nowhere because the defense now
sees it coming get him open down the
field and get him the football it's like
deontay johnson is the favorite receiver
and then juju smith shuster and then
it's claypool every once in a while
claypool is good enough that he should
be getting the ball far more often than
he does uh mike i agree claible is the
best receiver on their team claypool
might be the best player on their
offense period i mean you saw he catches
a screen behind the line of scrimmage he
almost goes up the sideline for a
70-yard touchdown i mean he's he's a
phenomenal talent and i do feel like
they need to ride that horse a little
bit more you know there's some third
downs during the game mike he's not in
the game i'm going what the most freaky
mismatched guy you got on the football
field is not on the game you know i know
he's a rookie but he is a mismatch
nightmare to your point he is literally
like dk metcalf jr watch out for year
two and he was open a bunch last night
and big ben missed him that was an issue
but i i still have faith in big ben they
gotta curtail their offensive pass game
a little bit to have a little more
variation like we've talked about it
can't be all five and ten yard passes
short right over the middle there's
gotta be more variance there and it just
can't be throw throw throw throw throw
every play with big ben at this age
there's got to be a little bit of a run
game i still got faith in the steelers i
do like i said i don't know if it ends
up in two wins for them at the end of
the year but they're still going to be a
scary team come playoff time when they
come marching in or whoever comes
marching in to play them and wouldn't it
be something as you mentioned during pft
live if it's the browns and the steelers
in week 17
and then in the wild card round that
happened in 2002 the last time the
browns were in the playoffs 38 32 the
steelers beat the browns at heinz field
maybe a rematch this year in pittsburgh
or
in cleveland that's it for this edition
of pft on yahoo sports thanks for some
of your time and we'll see you next time
see ya
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports